Speaker 1: Let's try let's try Jamie,
Jamie, from I can't tell where.
Speaker 3: Jamie, hello. Hello.
Hi, David. Hi. I had a question about I was
going to say I started watching your videos
during the pandemic when I had online school and
stuff. OK. And you really helped me out. Thank
you. But I had a question about, like the I know
you're focused on like twenty, twenty two, but
like twenty, twenty four is going to
scare me. Yeah. Like if I don't know
all the Republicans just kind of like seem like
the same, like cause I was like I don't know.
Speaker 1: Can you even tell. I mean
most of them, most of them don't even
most of them don't even talk about policy.
So I don't know how you can even tell.
Speaker 3: Right. Right. That's the
part that really scares me. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah. So I mean,
did you have a question about that?
Speaker 3: Oh I like what would Republican do
you think we would like do the least damage
like if they got voted in.
Speaker 1: I mean, I think somebody
like Mitt Romney maybe you know, it's like some
people are talking about Liz Cheney. I think Liz
Cheney is actually more more dangerous. She's
really she's more of a war hawk than Romney.
Speaker 3: Right? She agrees with
Trump. Yes, pretty much all the time.
Speaker 1: Ninety ninety three percent of the
time. Whereas Romney is more like in the 80s.
I mean, I think the thing of it I'm sure there's
other people who are moderate Republicans as
well. But in terms of like prominent
people, the thing about Romney is, um,
I think that on social stuff, he's more or less
indifferent from a policy standpoint. I know as
a Mormon, he probably has views I disagree with,
but I don't think he would like prosecute too much
social stuff. He might try on abortion, but I feel
like almost that that's pretty far gone. I think
it would be tough to do that. He doesn't strike me
as the guy who would try to start global conflict,
although I know there's examples of him saying
hawkish things. And so basically it would be like,
can we keep Romney in the middle rather than going
to the right on, you know, business regulation
and taxation and stuff like that? Like, it's
not I'm not saying I'd go and vote for Romney,
but if you said what prominent Republican
would if it has to be one, would I go with
it would be somebody like Romney? Probably.
Speaker 3: OK, well, thank you for answering
my question, David.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
Thank you for the call. I appreciate that.
Wow, what a polite caller. I love that. OK,
let's talk to a couple of other people, because
it is it's really quite a quite a special day.